pierre crackin bullheaded unruhe the UN
agency that helps Palestinians for more
than five years he was widely perceived
as one of the UN's best communicators
that from a humanitarian point of view
there's one very fundamental difference
but in recent months he's been at the
center of controversy after allegations
of mismanagement involving his inner
circle his deputy and his chief of staff
quit in July but it's believed his chief
adviser Maria Mohammed II seen here
remains in her job a leaked ethics
report said she was given a favored
position crumble to occur on most of his
trips using his authority to secure her
business class travel their relationship
the report said created a toxic
atmosphere the UN says after Secretary
General Antonio Guterres placed mr.
cracken Bell on administrative leave of
absence he finally resigned I think it
also important to reiterate that the
preliminary findings of the this iOS
report exclude fraud or misappropriation
of operational funds by the commissioner
general they are however managed they
were however managerial issues that need
to be addressed
someone was bumped up to business
because they had a very favorable
relationship with the commissioner
general would that amount to
misappropriation or fraud in your movie
I cannot go into further detail this
point I've spoken to ambassadors from
many of the main donor countries to
Unruh and to those close to the UN
Secretary General there's a real feeling
of dismay at the way things have worked
out there's been a distraction in recent
months from the important work the
agency does for Palestinians one gets
the sense from most of them that they
would have preferred the Commissioner
general to fall on his sword earlier
James BAE's al Jazeera at the United
Nations